start number five of the season for
julio urias tuesday against seattle
career high 11 strikeouts and just one
infield hit over seven shutout innings
it was absolutely fantastic and when you
think about julio you think about his
growth as a pitcher
you think about the breaking ball which
he made an adjustment going into that
last start against seattle he adjusted
the grip a little bit more and got it to
go more down and with that
going down more it might open up a
little bit more success for his up
fastball if there's any pitch that's
taken a step backwards with these elite
statistics it's his up fastball but with
the up fastball and a breaking ball that
goes a little bit more down all of a
sudden the success might come back for
that high fastball first three starts
earl he got seven swings and misses on
that breaking ball up to second goes
blandino two gone there's a eugenio
suarez right down the middle called
strike three swallows never got a chance
to swing at that one strikeout number
two for julio
and aureus has gotten through the first
putting a man on with a walk and
stranding him at second base former
westminster high school lion tyler mally
who grew up a dodger fan not too far
from here what a season he's having this
is a guy who last year was a long shot
to make the rotation was able to make it
because of some injuries at his best
here and he's doubled down on that 1-7-4
sixth in the national league so will
smith a chance to drive in a run no
score bases loaded one out pitch to
smith ground ball toward the middle it
is grabbed by suarez to india one on the
first double play and the dodgers
squander another bases loaded
opportunity one walk three strikeouts
against durias tyler stevenson the
catcher and now fastball induces weak
contact challenges rios running throw
had just enough steam to get over there
and muncie dug it out of the bounce
edwin has worked really hard on his
footwork and he had to use it all right
here
coming in for the
range and then also
making the wrong foot throw
and gets it online and that's the key
here and the reds are in business with
runners at second and third and nobody
out here's a eugenio suarez breaking
ball bounced both runners advance
looking one out at first suarez does the
job
winker scores castellanos glides to
third
and the reds have a one-nothing lead
castiano's at third base with one out
and here's senzel a strikeout victim his
first time up and dave roberts and the
dodgers will play the infield in
breaking ball swung at hit high in the
air to left it'll stay in the park but
it'll get the run home raley makes the
catch tagging at third cassiano's he's
coming home throw to the plate way late
castellano suzanna sacrifice fly for
cindel and the reds cash in on the
single and double that start of the
inning it's two nothing two outs after
the first two reach
and now locks who grounded out in his
first at-bat off of the injured list
tonight
drilled into right center field and
basic taylor around third he's on his
way to the plate
lux takes a big turnaround first as
muncie goes all the way from first to
third dodgers on the board an rbi base
hit for gavin lux it's 2-1 splitter they
finally get a hit on it splitter has
been perfect for mali
second time around the order maybe
they're getting a little used to it
understanding the rhythm that he uses it
more with left-handed hitters gavin was
on it a hit by pitch and a walk two men
are gone in the fifth inning and here's
nick castiano's castillanos rips it by
the shortstop seeger into left around
third farmer getting the wave the throw
home not in time
castellanos with an rbi single to left
the reds lead it three to one
there was no hesitancy
from j.r house to send the runner farmer
and if there's any kind of arm at all on
luke raleigh
he's got a chance for farmer at the
plate he got the baseball before farmer
rounded third
and still did not throw him out so
beatty pinch hitting beatty lifts a
fastball high in the air deep right
field castiano's back near the reds
bullpen and he makes the catch just in
front of the 360 sign he tacked on a run
with a hit and he gets a bunch of smiles
from his relievers it was not the
prettiest path and i think the ribbon of
a bit for this you're into the bullpen
though here's lucas sims 26 year old
from georgia
ninth appearance of the year brings in a
643 era
for pitch guy coming out of the bullpen
but he can bring it swing gonna miss
nothing fancy there just the heat right
on by will smith realio for two swing of
the miss back-to-back hayes for sims
that's six strikeouts by red's pitching
tonight kevin lux comes up with two way
in the sixth inning swing gonna miss
blew him away with a fastball up and out
of the zone and lucas sim strikes out
the side in the sixth
glandino walks gets a third base
nice run to push in right here grounded
to third
rios
and suarez grounds out not a clean throw
but amongst he handles well dodgers
within two tying run coming to the plate
in the form of corey seeger against
left-handed amir garrett he swings it's
a high drive deep center field way back
it goes it is gone corey seeger ties the
ball game with his fourth home run of
the year
it is three to three
lefty lefty he takes a mere garrett deep
and it's 3-3 in the seventh
lefties are now 5 for 11. and this is
quite a blast for him to dig out this
slider and to get down there and hit it
that hard you really got to stay in your
legs
and stay with it
that woke up this crowd tied at three as
we go to the ninth and joey vado will
pinch it for kyle farmer vatto cracks
one on the ground right side rios over
there and the shift flips on to get it
took him seven pitches but alexander
gets fotto
one gone to the knife he's lined in the
left field no it's knocked down by the
glove of rios picks it up with a bare
hand throws to first in time to get him
oh and a play by rios looked like that
ball was ticketed for left field
rios is a big man
leaped up in it
the apex of his leap was able to get the
webbing
of his glove with the ball just to knock
it down enough he kept it nearby picked
it up with a bare hand and on the run
her loader first but in time to retire
being hard what a play cookie bets
reaching first and keeping the ending
alive can corey seeger pull off an
encore to what he did in the seventh in
it ground ball rolled over right side
india is there fields throws got him
inning over bonus baseball late night
jesse winker will step to the point
hammered left center field and winker
got all of it back to the wall and going
two-run shot by jessie winker and the
reds have taken a 5-3 lead opposite
field juice pitch again
strength three called he struck him out
and the reds have won their first game
on this trip the seven game losing
streak is done